- So you were in Kansas City pre-Taylor.
- Yeah.
- Pre-Taylor, yes.
Well, same position, right?
Same team.
- Same team.
- Did he just break your record, Kelce?
- What?
- He broke my record-
- Do you have to be bringing that up?
- Oh, no.
- Thank you.
- No.
- No, no, because you tweeted about it!
You did something, that's how I know.
- Yeah, well, Travis Kelce.
- Yeah.
You said congratulations.
- Of course.
He's such a good dude.
And the whole Taylor Swift
thing now is becoming...
I was in the airport the other day
and this ten-year-old girl comes up to me.
And, you know, men usually
come up to me, football.
- Yeah.
- And occasionally like,
you know, a woman, but a 10-year-old girl.
I was like, "Oh, how cool.
I'm getting so popular
that 10-year-old girl comes up to me."
She goes, "Hi, is your name Tony?"
And I go, "Yes, it is."
She goes, "Do you know Travis Kelce?"
And I'm like...
(everyone laughing)
But I think it's great that
Taylor's done this for the NFL.
She's brought a whole new
audience, it's been great.
- Yeah.
- I will say, and there's a lot
of Swifties out there watching now.
But I will say, not because of that,
but I really got into football this year.
Like, I finally, I think I just broke down
'cause all my friends
and family are into it,
I'm literally alone on an island.
But I am obsessed, like, I'm
in fantasy football league.
- Oh, I was gonna say.
- Like, I love...
Do you do fantasy?
- I do fantasy.
I do it with my boys.
My boy River and Nikko,
we're in a little league
and all that stuff.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, we both have a River.
I forgot about that.
- Yeah, we got the River.
- Yeah, that's right.
Oh my God, I'm obsessed with it.
Are into football?
- I really like football.
I really do.
I really like marching bands, so I like...
(audience laughing)
Is that not cool to admit?
What? Are you kidding me?
The Ohio-Michigan game
and how the Ohio comes in.
- It's cool.
- Right?
- Wait, I literally just
lost my mic pack on that.
I like slid, no, I got it, Rosa.
I'm putting it on, I'm so bendy, okay.